et notre invités politiques ce matin ça
Sébastien Chenu bonjour bonjour
député du Nord vice-président du
rassemblement national on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par la presse du Nord la
Voix du Nord bonjour Julien Lecuyer
bonjour comment allez-vous monsieur
déplacements à travers le pays dans les
jours et les semaines à venir il sera
cet après-midi en Alsace
il sera jeudi dans l'Hérault et hier il
était à Saint-Denis pour un déplacement
privé mais il a été chahuté accueilli
par plusieurs manifestants est-ce que
vous cautionner ce chalut à l'encontre
du président
je trouve que c'est pas acceptable mais
Emmanuel Macron doit se rendre à
l'évidence les Français ne peuvent plus
le voir en peinture ils devaient venir
d'ailleurs à Denain moi je l'invite à
venir dans ma circonscription de Denain
là où les Français les premiers lui ont
dit qu'ils étaient hostiles à la réforme
des retraites je l'invite à venir voir
ce que les Français ont envie de lui
dire il va pas être accueilli avec des
bouquets de fleurs Emmanuel Macron la
politique qu'il mène elle est contre le
peuple français il impose au peuple
français des lois dans les Français
ultra majoritairement ne veulent pas
donc ensuite qu'il soit accueilli qu'ils
soient chahutés bah oui oui
effectivement ça fait partie des choses
parce qu'en plus il a cherché à
bâillonner l'utilisation du 49-3
l'utilisation d'un certain nombre
d'argucides parlementaires et juridique
font que il a cherché à baillonner à
limiter les débats et les Français lui
en veulent terriblement il y a beaucoup
de ressentiments dans le pays Sébastien
Chenu le lendemain de l'adresse
d'Emmanuel Macron lundi vous avez réagi
en jugeant que sa principale faute je
vous cite avait été de dire qu'il allait
continuer comme si de rien n'était mais
qu'est-ce que vous ayez qu'ils disent
qu'il s'excuse qu'il retient sa réforme
sachant que s'il faisait ça il pouvait
tout aussi bien démissionner mais vous
n'êtes déjà quelque chose d'abord s'il
avait présenté des excuses aux Français
pour la façon dont il a plongé le pays
dans un chaos et une impasse sociale
politique démocratique ça aurait pu être
accueilli avec beaucoup d'attentes à
l'élection présidentielle pour vous
c'est pas un engagement mais Emmanuel
Macron a eu un discours totalement
incantatoire lundi soir avec des vœux
pieux avec des choses totalement
irréalistes j'ai rencontré des
professionnels de santé dernièrement il
nous dit qu'en 30 jours il va régler le
problème des urgences françaises en 100
jours pardon ensemble
2024 enfin en 1 an 10 ans le problème
des urgences françaises mais enfin
est-ce que il a bien en tête ce que cela
veut dire non je pense que le Président
de la République se moque des Français
je pense que c'est un exercice que de
communication mais surtout dans lequel
il y a un vide sidéral qui m'est apparu
on a du fait qu'il est parlé 3 minutes
des retraites c'est qu'il n'a pas du
tout par exemple parler de l'inflation
pas du tout parler du pouvoir d'achat
du prix des courses aujourd'hui le
principal vous attendiez à des mesures
concrètes c'est ça ben oui et nous on en
a fait des propositions sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur la vie chère on a demandé
qu'on passe comme dans d'autres pays la
TVA à 0 % sur un panier de 100 produits
de première nécessité
en Espagne
mais on regardait l'indice des des
en Espagne le prix de alimentaire moyen
a Bondy de 14% en janvier et de 16% en
mars ce qui montre que les la mesure a
été contrecarrée par une hausse brutale
des prix ça vous fait peur parce que
vous comptez appliquer non parce que moi
je pense que dans ces dispositions que
nous proposons mais c'est aussi la
baisse de la TVA sur les énergies à 5 et
demi pour cent mais ça c'est l'Union
européenne
la sortie du marché l'Union européenne
ne permet pas du tout ah non pas du tout
elle ne peut pas elle n'accepte pas les
baisses de TVA sur les produits non non
là il y a plus il y a plusieurs choses
la sortie du marché européenne
l'électricité et tout à fait possible
les techniques pour certains pays l'ont
fait l'Espagne d'ailleurs aussi je crois
de façon momentanée autrement année ou
durable je me rappelle de Bruno Le Maire
nous racontant qu'il allait étudier ça
qu'il allait regarder ça c'était il y a
six mois déjà devant le Parlement rien
il ne se passe rien en réalité ils l'ont
fait aucun geste le trimestre
anti-inflation pour vous c'est c'est de
la colle c'est de la colle c'est de la
colle on met des affichettes c'est tout
mais
[Musique]